digamos que tenemos una cuerda y le
damos una sacudida verán que hay un
pulso de onda que viaja a través de esta
cuerda y aquí hay una pregunta qué
pasaría si otra persona que se encuentre
al otro extremo de la cuerda también
enviara un pulso de onda hacia la
primera onda qué va a pasar cuando se
superpongan vamos a tratar de calcularlo
digamos que tenemos aquí una onda que
viene por acá y si esto es un cuadrado
es un poco extraño y deben ser muy
talentosos para poder hacer esto en una
cuerda pero esto no tiene que ser por
fuerza una cuerda puede ser una onda de
sonido o una onda electromagnética puede
ser cualquier onda el hecho de que sea
un cuadrado es solo para facilitarnos el
análisis digamos que tenemos esta onda
que viene por acá y hay otra onda que
viene en sentido opuesto hay que aclarar
que esta es la misma cuerda no son dos
cuerdas es una sola y sobre esta misma
cuerda hay dos ondas que se están
aproximando entre ellas y para
hacer esto realista como el sol o una
cuerda esto luciría así aquí está la
cuerda y luego viene este pulso de acá
así que esta línea de abajo no debería
estar esta cuerda se movió aquí arriba
ya que fue perturbada por la onda luego
regresa a cero y de nuevo aquí no hay
dos cuerdas es la misma cuerda así que
aquí la cuerda se va hacia arriba y
luego vuelve a bajar pero en estos
ejemplos no quiero estar borrando esta
línea cada vez haría que el vídeo se
tardará mucho así que cada vez que vean
una cuerda abajo de un pulso vamos a
imaginar que no hay ninguna cuerda aquí
y qué va a pasar cuando estas ondas se
superpongan vamos a averiguarlo tomo una
de las ondas y la muevo acá y la otra
onda va a estar por encima de esta
primera y aquí voy a tener interferencia
de onda la interferencia de onda es el
término para cuando tenemos dos o más
ondas que se superponen en la misma
región aquí que es lo que va a pasar
bueno pues la cuerda no puede estar en
dos lugares al mismo tiempo
sólo hay una cuerda y esta cuerda va a
tener una forma y para averiguar cuál
será la forma de la onda total vamos a
sumar las contribuciones de ambas ondas
que se están superponiendo en otras
palabras si quiero conocer la altura de
la onda total a esto le llamo 7 t de
total esto va a ser igual a la altura de
la primera onda que llamamos de 1 más la
altura de la segunda onda que llamaremos
de 2 y si están familiarizados con la
ecuación de la onda pueden poner la
ecuación de cada una de las ondas y
sumarlas entre sí de manera que
obtendremos la ecuación de la onda total
pero muchas veces no tenemos que usar
todo el armamento matemático de la
ecuación de la onda simplemente podemos
ver la imagen y calcular cuál será la
altura de la onda total vamos a hacerlo
pongamos aquí unas líneas de fondo que
nos ayudarán con las medidas de la
altura
esta es una unidad de altura aquí hay
dos unidades aquí hay tres unidades de
altura
ciudades podrían ser centímetros o
metros pero no importa aquí diremos que
son una unidad dos unidades o tres
unidades y para averiguar cómo va a
lucir la onda total sumamos las
contribuciones de cada onda individual
ambas ondas son cero aquí así que esto
es fácil 0 0 es cero y llegamos aquí la
onda azul tiene una unidad de altura
la onda morada tiene una altura de dos
unidades es la onda que denominamos onda
dos y el que vayan en direcciones
opuestas no importa pues en este momento
se están superponiendo así que una
unidad de altura más dos unidades de
altura nos van a dar tres unidades de
altura por lo que mi onda total va a
verse así
y si me preguntaran cuál es la forma de
la onda total sería esta si esto fuera
una cuerda se vería así una onda con una
altura de tres unidades ya que estas dos
ondas se están trasladando esto estuvo
sencillo cómo podemos complicarlo pues
podemos preguntarnos cómo se verán estas
ondas cuando están parcialmente
superpuestas como se verá aquí cuando
están traslapadas a mitad de camino
bueno vamos a encontrar la onda total
usando nuevamente esta regla sumamos
ambas contribuciones para encontrar el
total
aquí tenemos 000 sigue siendo 0 y
llegamos a este punto en este punto la
onda 1 que es la de color azul tiene una
altura de una unidad y la altura de la
onda morada que es la onda 2 sigue
siendo 0 0 + 1 es 1
por lo que mi onda total se va a ver así
en esta región y en esta otra región la
ola azul tiene una altura de una unidad
y la onda morada tiene una altura de dos
unidades uno más dos es tres por lo que
mi onda total aquí en esta región va a
verse así en este punto la onda azul
baja por lo que aquí tenemos que
encontrar un nuevo valor ya que en este
punto la onda azul llega a cero la onda
morada sigue teniendo un valor de 220 es
2 por lo que mi onda total aquí va a
tener 2 unidades y mi onda total va a
verse así así que mi cuerda total cuando
tengo estas ondas que se están
superponiendo a mitad de camino se ve
algo así lo que si esto fuera una cuerda
sería tremendamente difícil de dejar
esta forma pero las señales electrónicas
pueden tener ondas cuadradas y se verían
así si estuvieran superponiéndose ahora
les quiero advertir sobre algo de esta
idea de interferencia de ondas que es
una idea genial pero hay que tener
cuidado
ya que la interferencia de honda podría
confundirnos pues en efecto conforme
estas dos ondas se están trasladando nos
van a dar una forma diferente una onda
diferente
tendremos una distorsión porque la onda
total será igual a la suma de estas dos
ondas pero estas ondas van a pasarse
entre sí lo que es genial ya que de otra
manera no podríamos hacer llamadas ni
enviarnos mensajes de texto ya que los
teléfonos de todos los demás también
están enviando mensajes y llamadas en el
mismo aire estas ondas electromagnéticas
están viajando por el mismo aire todas a
la vez
si estás rebotarán entre sí si estas
ondas chocarán y se volvieran corruptas
si cambiara la información que llevan de
manera que su forma no fuera la misma
que tenían antes de la colisión sería
muy difícil hacer llamadas y enviar los
mensajes pero afortunadamente la
interferencia de onda solo ocurre cuando
se están trasladando las ondas pero
las ondas pasan a través de ellas sin
afectarse entre sí así que continúan su
camino con la forma que traían lo cual
es bastante bueno ahora veamos otro
ejemplo un poquito más complicado
quitamos todo esto y ahora digamos que
tenemos estos dos pulsos de onda el
mismo pulso o cuadrado y este pulso
triangular medio extraño de aquí y esto
se van atrás la par este pulso de ondas
llega hasta acá y el pulso triangular
también llega aquí y tenemos esta forma
extraña en donde hay dos elementos
separados pero aquí nuestra cuerda no se
va a separar en dos sigue siendo una
sola cuerda así que cómo se verá nuestra
onda total pues vamos a usar las mismas
reglas que usamos antes para calcular la
interferencia de onda vamos a sumar las
contribuciones de cada una de las ondas
en un punto en particular para encontrar
el valor total de nuestra onda en ese
mismo lugar
bueno aquí tenemos 0 + 0 que nos da 0 lo
cual es fácil y ahora
a este punto en donde el valor de mi
onda azul mi onda 1 es de una unidad y
el valor de la onda morada es 0 por lo
que 0 + 1 va a ser 1 esta parte es un
poco extraña porque tenemos el cambio en
la onda morada pero llegamos hasta este
otro punto que el cálculo es más fácil
ya que aquí mi onda azul mi onda 1 tiene
una unidad de altura y la onda morada
tiene digamos que aquí es menos 1 tiene
una altura de menos una unidad la onda
azul es 1 y la onda morada es menos 1
por lo que uno menos 1 es 0 y después de
aquí va a seguir siendo 0 pero qué forma
tendrá en el medio pues la respuesta más
sencilla de hecho es la correcta
simplemente cae así porque es eso bueno
vamos a considerar un punto en el medio
en el punto de en medio la onda azul
tiene una altura de una unidad la onda
morada tiene un valor de menos un medio
por lo que uno menos uno medio va a ser
un medio positivo o consideremos el
valor aquí el valor de la onda azul aquí
es de una unidad y el valor de la onda
morada es digamos menos tres cuartos por
lo que el valor de la onda total sería
de un cuarto positivo y es por eso que
esto cae linealmente ya que esta onda
morada de aquí está quitando cada vez un
poco más la altura de esta onda azul y
nuestra onda total luciría así así luce
la onda total cuando estas dos ondas se
superponen por lo que esta técnica de
sumar los valores de cada una de las
ondas individuales en un punto se llama
principio de superposición que es un
título un poco intimidante para algo que
realmente es muy sencillo que para
encontrar la onda total tenemos que
sumar los valores de las ondas
individuales en ese punto
en resumen interferencia de onda es el
término que usamos cuando dos o más
ondas
se superponen en la misma región y para
encontrar el valor de la onda total en
esa región en donde las ondas se están
superponiendo o donde se traslapan el
principio de superposición nos dice que
debemos de sumar los valores de cada una
de las zonas individuales en esa
posición para encontrar el valor de la
onda total en ese mismo lugar